in this video i take you into the past
to what it was like vlogging in the 70s
and compare it with how far we have come
today or have we are we may be further
behind
hey i'm don mace i've carried this book
around with me for the past 10 years
it's filled with the most challenging
ideas i've ever had and this show is
dedicated to getting them done
welcome to the brew show
in front of me i have two types of
cameras but my oh my are they different
on this side i have the iphone 13 pro
max and on this side i have the ariflex
sr3 super 16 millimeter film camera
cameras where the dated or new edge all
kind of work the same way they all have
a photosensitive material film tape or
digital sensor film is a strip of
transparent plastic film base coated on
the one side with a gelatin emulsion
containing microscopically small light
sensitive silver halide crystals
secondly a shutter which opens and
closes to expose the sensor to light for
controlled amount of time per frame and
a lens which directs light through a
gate onto the sensor and determines the
field of view of the image and in the
case of film cameras is a mechanism
known as the magazine which holds the
film and moves the reel past the shutter
frame by frame digital cameras have a
sensor built into the body of the camera
which converts light into an electrical
signal recorded onto a memory card as a
video file motion picture film comes in
different sizes measured by their width
and the cost increases with the size the
most common formats are 8 and super 8
millimeter 16 and super 16 millimeter 35
millimeter 65 and 70 millimeter i'll be
using super 16 millimeter which costs
around 200 per 400 foot roll which gives
you just under 11 minutes of footage
super 16 millimeter film cameras are
also far lighter than a 35 millimeter
counterpart which is hard to believe
when i lift it up
this thing's pretty heavy
these days capturing video is far more
accessible as just about everyone
carries the camera around in their
pocket at the time of recording this
video for around 1 200 you can get the
iphone 13 pro max the sensor on this
phone captures 4k prores which is a
widely used format on film sets it has
three different cameras with a wide
ultra wide and telephoto lens the
sensors on iphones are far smaller than
film meaning they cannot achieve a
shallow depth of field however the
iphone 13 pro max now has cinematic mode
which allows you to artificially achieve
a shallow depth of field you can pull
focus with the top of the screen or even
change your focus in post
autofocus does not exist with foam
cameras so you have to manually turn the
focus ring on the lens often going as
far as to measure out the distance
between your subject and the camera with
a measuring tape but how much does it
cost to shoot on phone considering that
the camera is just the beginning you'll
need a lens a matte box batteries an lcd
monitor a hand grip a tripod rails a
follow focus an easy rig a light meter
and nd filters all of this rented from a
local gear house for one day costs
around 1 500 and if i had to buy it all
it would cost around sixty five thousand
dollars on top of that it's gonna cost
me one thousand two hundred dollars for
eight hundred feet of film which will
give me just over twenty minutes of
footage totaling the cost of rental and
film to two thousand seven hundred
dollars per day
famous photographer chase jarvis once
said the best camera is the one that's
with you well that would usually refer
to my iphone today i'll have the reflex
sr3 so let's find out if the artistic
look of 16 millimeter is worth the
effort or if the cinematic mode on the
iphone offers more bang for your buck in
order to compare these two cameras in
the most practical and visual way i'm
going to make a day in the life vlog
what it would have been like to vlog in
1970 versus vlogging in 2022 where i'm
gonna go through the city of cape town
and shoot two beautiful montages one
shot digitally on the iphone 13 pro max
and one shot on film stock on the arri
flex sr3 super 16 millimeter phone
camera
in order to transport all the gear
needed to make the 60 millimeter camera
compatible with the iphone i'm gonna
take this normal shopping cart and
transform it into what i call the
trolley cam
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
okay this is a scary part i've got to
load this film stuck into the magazine
in this loading bag this is not usually
the environment when we do this and it's
very bright
oh okay i think i got it and my magazine
patreon
[Music]
good morning cape town ah
[ __ ] that was wasting a lot of fun
one thing i'm worried about is two
separate exposures what i know with the
film stock is i feel like there is more
latitude so we might be able to expose
for both
[Music]
as much work as it is to shoot on 60
millimeter i feel like you have to work
less to get the shot right like
everything seems cinematic
[Music]
difficult when all you have is a certain
amount of feet in a row like really
thinking and considering all the shots
since it'll be ridiculous to put the 60
millimeter camera on a drone and the
iphone doesn't fly i'm going to recreate
the drone shot with a scissor lift
look how much i've shot just for one
drone recreation shot
[Music]
that's fine
okay i've just finished loading the film
into the cans with the iphone
i just airdrop it straight to the laptop
this should take about five to seven
days to get developed and scanned at 4k
so when it arrives i'll check in with
you then which should be now i just got
the scans back
open them now
and then i'm gonna start to edit
oh it's good it's really really good
now to edit these two pieces
okay i am done it's just busy exporting
as soon as it's done i'm going to show
you the two different forms for you to
choose which one looks better which one
feels better which one essentially is
better enjoy
[Music]
good morning cape town
[Music]
that's by far my favorite way to start
the day it's time to say goodbye to gabs
and i'm gonna head into the city
[Music]
for your money
[Music]
thanks for watching this not so normal
day in my life video shot on 60
millimeter film
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning cape town
that was by far my favorite way to start
the day
now i'm gonna say goodbye to gabs and
head into the city center
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
thanks for watching this not so normal
day in my life vlog filmed on my iphone
on the one side we have film which is
considered an arty but it takes a lot of
time and it's super expensive on the
other side we have digital which is
highly accessible far cheaper but it
looks more clinical i had a lot of fun
shooting on both but in conclusion i
would say to go with the old school
mentality of film to be more precious
with where you point your camera to be
more considered and then to treat
digital with this mindset this video is
made possible by discovery plus which is
the home of truly great filmmaking we're
putting in the extra effort to telling
the most compelling story is what it's
all about and one of my favorite
documentaries on discovery plus right
now is beyond borders by my good friend
louis cole or who you know as fun for
louis and jp sculpts in this documentary
they proved the power of using smaller
more accessible digital cameras to
capture the most incredible moments also
if you sign up right now you get a 14
day discovery plus promotion using the
promo code dan mace this offer is valid
until the 25th of june 2022 so click on
the link in my description to redeem
your promotion code now other than that
don't forget you're awesome brew and
i'll see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you